la fractura política en haití parece
profundizarse día a día la oposición
acusa al presidente joven el mois de
perpetuarse en el poder
al no haber dejado su cargo este 7 de
febrero pero él rechaza esto y alega que
su mandato termina en un año
no soy un dictador sé que mi mandato
termine el 7 de febrero de 2022 no andan
de humala los dictadores son personas
que toman el poder y no saben cuándo se
van a volver a moix defiende que su
periodo de gobernanza es por cinco años
mientras que los opositores aseguran que
la constitución limita los mandatos
cuatro años la tensión en el país
solamente ha ido en aumento y este
domingo el presidente denunció un
intento de golpe de estado en el que se
detuvo a 23 personas el juez y vi que el
decil ha hecho un complot para dar un
golpe de estado para desestabilizar al
país el poder judicial es uno de los
mayores enemigos de moix a ellos se
suman la iglesia católica y el colegio
de abogados pero el ejército se ha
mantenido leal al mandatario algo que no
ha impedido que este lunes la oposición
nombrará a un presidente interino
estas se han replicado y hubo heridos
por bala
declaro que aceptó la elección de la
oposición y la sociedad civil de servir
a mi país como presidente interino de la
transición
[Música]
haití es el país más pobre de américa la
crisis que sufre se prolonga desde hace
décadas y sobrepasa el plano político